I'm Mike and I created Surfside surf set
really started out of necessity I
couldn't get to the ocean I really loved
the way the body type in the fitness
level that I attained while surfing so I
needed to create a workout that can
mimic that hey this is Mike from surf
set we're here to work on the pop ups
with your surf set pocket 3-minute
workout so first move I just want you to
take your hands put them up on the rails
which is the side of the surfboard we're
going to walk our feet nice and slow to
the back of the board
find that balance it's going to move a
little bit lower down nice and slow
alright so there's three movements in
the pop up it's gonna be a push up it's
gonna be a Burpee and then there's
actually gonna be a core rotation which
is going to be a full pop ups bring the
hands out to the side from here all I
want to do hands on your shoulders
explosive push up so down up nice and
controlled up a little pause at the top
stabilize come on back down second
movement is going to bring those feet
forward to our hands okay as we pop up
bring that hand's underneath you can
either walk and come on up
stand or we can go a little bit faster
hop forward come to standing two squats
right back down hopper walk those feet
back now this time we're going to have
that core rotation we're gonna go slow
first we'll go to each side first ones
nice and basic so we have in those hands
on the shoulder walk that left foot
forward we're going to slightly turn to
that right side stabilize let's go to
one now and I think it a little bit more
difficult squat down left knee left
elbow nice and controlled
all right so now I want to come back
down and we're going to go to the left
side this time so right foot forward
push up right foot up turn to that left
side a couple squats let's go to one
stabilize two squats one two now we're
in that left knee left elbow right knee
right elbow nice controlled stabilize
all right
so there's three movements in the pop up
so the first move explosive push up
second movement is going to be a burpee
and then there's actually gonna be a
core rotation and that's your three
minutes surf set workout make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes